all right I I apologize for to the fact
that we're getting started a little late
tonight and it's not our fault but
nonetheless here we are I want to
introduce Philip Zelikow thank him for
coming he's the white birkat Miller
professor of history at the University
of Virginia you I'm sure know his work
as the director of the 911 Commission
staff which produced 911 commission
report perhaps the only presidential
commission that has ever been a
best-seller and a graphic novel I might
add not a novel ice it's a graphic
nonfiction but but one of the striking
things about as I'm sure many of you
already know is that it reads in parts
like a novel and one thing that that
we've learned since it came out is how
it is that it was the express intention
from the outset to create a report that
wouldn't read like a report but would
read already as history and the best
kind of history the kind of history that
was true to life and that would provide
a compelling account of these events in
a way that would imprint itself on the
public imagination and the way people
had just begun to come to terms with
these tragic events and I think that
that historians took some pride you know
and the fact that this was the work of
an historian and also of a number of
historians in assisting him in this work
because in fact it was a demonstration
of the power of history and the
importance of history because then as
now and perhaps forever there will be
many who would look back at these events
very differently who would find it too
hard to believe that these tragic events
could be the work of a relatively small
number of people on both sides people
making terrible mistakes with terrible
consequences who prefer to believe that
it was an even smaller number of people
perhaps who were orchestrating all of it
and you know if you think of the
importance of history and
heart is helping people understand the
world as it is and how it came to be
that way then I think you would agree
that our speaker tonight Philip Zelikow
has been on the front lines in that
fight for history and I want to thank
him again for coming he's going to be
speaking tonight about the uses of
history I hope they'll speak about some
of the history that I was just talking
about but I know too is going to be
talking about the larger agenda for this
research program coming to terms with
trans national even global problems and
finally before I let him take the podium
let me just once again thank the people
who made all this possible i want to
thank again Roger hertog for his
generosity and creating this this
initiative I want to thank to the Arnold
Saltzman Institute for co-sponsoring
this lecture series and finally the
School of International public affairs
for providing us with this venue so
thank you and thank you all for coming
what I'd like to do is to start out with
a story about how one particular country
decided to build an atomic bomb I've
chosen to focus on uses of history with
respect to nuclear weapons and the issue
of nuclear proliferation because that's
a theme for this speakers program and
for the hertog global strategy seminar
this summer and the particular country
i'm going to start with kick the country
i'm going to tell my little story about
it's actually a story we should know
reasonably well it's the story of how
the United States of America chose to
build the atomic bomb I think it's an
interesting story this is in principle
the story we should understand better
than any other and so I when I looked at
this story a little bit I was actually
surprised that there is a lot of
questions and mysteries surrounding this
story now there are a lot of books about
the building of the atomic bomb like
Richard roses book and several others
they're very good books the conventional
narrative about this story is basically
the US government discovers that there
are these amazing things that can be
done
scientists are organized under the
leadership of a blustery Colonel
promoted to general and exchanges or
incentive for him to take the job of
having to manage all these unruly
scientists and so general Leslie groves
and J robert Oppenheimer put together
the team and they overcome myriad
scientific challenges and they build the
bomb and the central protagonists and
the conventional narrative of the
building at the bomb our groves and
Oppenheimer are the different and the
nuclear scientists and all the
challenges they overcome and in the
roads book it's basically a narrative
about the scientists discovering the
potential and then overcoming the
challenges and then wrestling with the
moral and ethical implications of what
they're doing but one of the things that
this narrative mrs. is how interesting
and odd that it was that the United
States chose to do this at all there
were several countries during the Second
World War that looked at the issue of
whether to try to build an atomic bomb
in addition to the United States Germany
Nazi Germany looked at it the Soviet
Union looked at it Britain looked at it
and then basically shrugged their
shoulders and turned the problem over to
the United States Japan looked at it
just a tiny bit had a few scientists who
entered stood it a little bit all of
them but the United States basically
said too hard and did not mount a
serious effort to build the bomb until
actually the United States had already
proven that it could be done and then
once they had once there the whole world
had seen a proof of concept than others
were more motivated so actually the
United States was unique alone in
deciding to make an all-out effort to
build an atomic bomb let me just
emphasize this praise all-out effort if
you don't make an all-out effort you
don't build an atomic bomb the effort to
build the atomic bomb was the most
expensive industrial engineering project
ever undertaken by the United States of
America to that time it was and it was a
vast project it made incredible claims
on the resources of the country even at
one point
non trivial fraction of the entire
electricity supply of the country so a
fantastically expensive effort and the
decision was made to do this in order to
build a weapon that no one had ever
proven would work now how many of you
know of military programs that will
basically spend unlimited amounts of
money on concepts that have actually
never even been proven in a laboratory
make the most colossal bet the richest
country in the world can possibly make
on an entirely unproven concept and was
unique in doing that and by the way I'll
even add that I think had the United
States not built an atomic bomb during
the Second World War it's actually not
clear to me when or possibly even if an
atomic bomb ever is guilt because of
this tremendous effort you had that
someone had the muster under simply
incredible emergency extraordinary
conditions to overcome all these hurdles
to prove it could be done in doing
because to most people who looked at it
this is kind of it's an intriguing
theoretical idea but it's just not
practical so then a good question to
turn to is when exactly was the decision
made to do this as an all-out project
when was that decision made my judgment
of this focuses to just pick one month
September 1942 by the way it's the dis
interesting decision is not the decision
that gee let's conduct research on an
atomic bomb project that's once you find
out that theoretically this can be done
the decision to set up a research
program is not a hard decision the
decision even to set up an R&D program
we ought to have some people who kind of
are working on this that's also not a
hard decision the hard decision is let's
put this into production and give it the
highest priorities and claims on all
resources of the United States if
necessary trumping all other claims by
the way edited in the image of the
United States's we had so much stuff we
could do anything we didn't have to make
hard choices wrong we were making hard
choices all over the place
no there wasn't that much deal in the
United States be able to do everything
and i'll come back to just what kind of
hard choices were being made the same
time this decision must be made so the
wind let's say September 1942 that's
actually when the decision is made to
create the Manhattan engineering
district to put it into a full-scale
production to give it the priorities in
the Army Navy munitions board that would
allow it to access to the raw materials
that by the way it had not been getting
for the previous six months and had been
claiming again and again can we please
have this deal can we please have this
and have been told no you can mainly
being told no by general Lucius clay who
is actually a fairly senior figure in
the army and you know or we're going to
get Danny ver Bush after you okay the
answer is still no clay said would say
this all changed in September 1942 and
then they just put Leslie groves and
charge the most hard-charging
engineering officer they know of in the
US Army who had just finished building
the Pentagon for them and well so the
first question is when same question is
who made this decision by the way not
Leslie groves not J robert Oppenheimer
not any atomic scientist so who actually
makes this decision well it's by the way
anyone know the answer to this question
there are you there at least five key
names for that you could think of maybe
six or seven one of them is not Franklin
Roosevelt who is however super generally
very supportive you know we have like
written evidence of like a forward note
he wrote at some point saying go ahead
with this but like that's in 1941 where
you know he's been told this is an
interesting idea and rose up to ya
pursue it this decision is made the four
people I would single out our Henry
Stimson George Marshall Vannevar Bush
James Conant and then if you stretched a
little bit more working for Simpson man
named Harvey Bundy and Robert Patterson
another person working from marshal
named steyr another person worked for
Marshall name is very important name
Brown somerville who is the runs that
boring part of the army that deals with
supply which means kind of buying
everything for the army which is
actually kind of a big job at that time
so though but that's basically the
people who make this they actually are
on a special committee that's working on
the atomic project called an s-1
committee and but actually if you look
into why they made this decision it's
actually kind of it's not hard to find
really good evidence on this point they
didn't write much stuff down about it I
mean we know we have good evidence that
up to about a certain point they're
asking again and again for materials
that they need and are basically being
told no we're not going to give you the
double a priority you want you know you
have to stand in line with all the
others we're not going to quit building
a whole you know Armored Division worth
of tanks so that you can build your
cockamamie thing just to help put this
in perspective no one at this point in
September 42 had even never done a chain
reaction the Fermi pile in Chicago
produced the first chain reaction that
even proved that that principle was
theoretically possible that actually
done it they didn't do that till
December of 1942 so the point this
decision is made no one has even
produced a chain reaction even in a
laboratory setting why did they make
this decision in September 1942 why did
this group of people who are not kind of
notorious casino gamblers make about the
most colossal gamble it's imaginable for
them to make that's actually fairly
interesting and let me now give you a
little more context about some stuff
that's going on at the time one of the
things that's going on at the time is
this is actually a period of crisis in
American war production if you read the
official histories it's interesting you
know the atomic histories just do the
atomic history then the histories I've
say the building up the army ground
forces they just do the history the army
ground forces they don't really notice
that hey that decisions being made
the same time as that decision as being
made at that decision here's what's
happening is basically the American
armed forces put together a victory plan
in 1941 that says here's the way we're
going to build up the Army and the Navy
and the Air Corps to win the war I mean
basically here's how big it's going to
be and therefore here's here's how many
people were going to need and here's how
much stuff we need to buy here's how
many training camps we need to build you
can deceive how important these
decisions are in terms of all the things
that would flow from these decisions and
their basic plan is we're going to build
a gigantic army it's going to be an army
that's going to have about 200 divisions
we're going to build a gigantic Air
Corps and we're going to build a
gigantic Navy and then by about the
summer of nineteen forty-two they
realize that they cannot do it all they
just can't have it all there just aren't
enough people there aren't enough
resources to do it all and actually
they're going to have to make really big
cuts not like five or ten percent at the
margin cuts across the board something
there have to make some really big
strategic choices to change the plan how
they're going to win the war by the way
the big army plan was totally natural to
them America had mobilized for all-out
war this is the third time it had
happened in the history of the country
the fur and the American Way of war is
established by the first time which was
grant on Richmond and grant on Richmond
is get the biggest army you can and just
bludgeon the other guy until they are
bloody and lying on the ground and you
just win a war of attrition and you win
that and so the next time they mobilize
for all-out war which is in the First
World War we built the largest army we
could and ship two million people to
France to fight it we didn't even bother
so much about getting the artillery for
them or getting planes for them we
bought all that stuff from the British
and French who are happy to sit we
mainly just got it to cut the soldiers
there because we were just going to get
such an overwhelming number of soldiers
there and the British and French would
help equip them and that was going to
turn the tide of the war and that felt
and they were going to do the same thing
again third time around is we're going
to need an overwhelming back because
we're going to actually have to beat the
bear mocked in Europe because Marshalls
preferred plan for how to win the war
or is we're gonna have to land in our in
France and put the biggest goddamn army
we can field into the field and we're
going to have to beat the ver moch than
win the war and there is no fancy
tap-dancing way around that was his
approach by September 1942 every aspect
of that plan is falling apart the basic
plan to get ashore in Europe and
immediately open a second front in
France in part in ERDA desperately hope
to somehow keep the Germans from winning
the war in Russia which they feared the
Germans were going to win in 1942 that's
collapsed there Marshall is so angry
about the collapse of that that he wants
to actually in the Sun July of 42 he
asks Roosevelt so well if we're not
going to do this seriously let's just
switch our whole main effort to the
Pacific and abandon Germany first and
Roosevelt vetoes that and says no we're
going to do something in that theater
and more or less forces Marshall very
much against his will to adopt the plan
well we'll do this invasion in North
Africa in Western North Africa which
will mountain later in 1942 even though
we mean we know that that means that it
compromises our ability to do a
cross-channel attack even in 1943 and
there's a lot written on a lot of this
strategic turmoil of the summer of
nineteen forty two at the same time that
the main strategy for coming to grips
with the enemy is beginning to dissolve
the army the giant army that was going
to do it you know they can't do that and
have the air corps and have the Navy
something's gotta give and the decision
that they make which they make in fall
of nineteen forty two and then is
gradually put into effect in early 43 is
what army historians have called the 100
division gamble is what they did is they
basically cut the plan size of the army
in half in half instead of a 200
division army we're going to go for a
hundred actually will end up being only
about 88 we will not cut the size of the
Navy at all
we will not cut the size of the Air
Corps at all same number of groups for
the Air Corps same number of carriers
battleships and ships for the Navy so it
is not kind of a lowest common
denominator they made a strategic choice
we're going to take it pretty much all
out of the Army's hide you underneath
that you're saying there is clearly some
kind of concept underneath that decision
about how it is we're now going to win
World War two that's different from the
concept they had six months earlier yeah
there is and now I'd remind you again
that that's the same period of time in
which they authorized the a-bomb project
you're beginning to sense something here
what else is going on a couple of other
things they are told that the science on
this is compelling none of these people
as I said earlier our atomic scientists
why is it that they are so willing to
make a colossal bet on unproven science
is because clearly someone whom they
trust utterly has told them to place all
your chips on that number who is that
person that person probably above all is
vanier bush who is not probably very
well-known person he is the head of at
that time of something called the office
of scientific research and development
in the United States government he is in
effect he's an unusual person he is not
a nuclear physicist he's not actually
physicist at all but he is a scientist
and he in effect has become the
ambassador of the world of science to
the world of practical men and afraid
they pretty much are all men in 1942 and
somehow Bush has just gotten a
relationship built up where a bush says
put your bet on that the army guys say
yes mr. bush that's what we'll do
because we trust you he had built up a
credibility with them as someone who
could bridge these two worlds
that they believed he understood
practical problems and that if he told
them to bet on something they were going
to bet on it so Bush is coming up with
things like you know let's put this kind
of emphasis on something called
proximity fuses let's put this kind of
effort on the radar effort and so on and
a number of other innovations and Bush
has this remarkable role in that they
trust him he's developed such a high
quality relationship and there was a
relationship too with Harry Hopkins and
with President Roosevelt that if that
Bush can vouch for this and Bush in turn
relies a lot on Jim Conant who is the
president of Harvard University who is
himself not the key a not a key atomic
scientist but who understands more of
the physics and understands it well
enough that he feels he can calibrate it
more and he is seized with it what
happens if you take Bush and content out
of the picture I mean there we actually
could see what had happened because
there were earlier versions of this as a
research project in our government in
which it was utterly languishing for
months and months and months you know
moving about a centimeter at a time and
even earlier in 1942 we can kind of see
the way it was going as an R&D project
in which case there it's it there's no
chance there would have been a bomb
developed by the end of World War two if
indeed one had ever been developed at
all so there is unusual it's not just
the science it's the way the science is
represented to the halls of power and
the credibility that that had and by the
way it's possible that bush and
could have been wrong but it just turns
out that they weren't in this particular
case there's also a sense of and at
which Bush and conant push very hard is
this is not only a possible way to win
the war but it's also a possible way to
lose it because we think the Germans are
working on this actually did they
thought the Germans were by way ahead of
them because most of this work had
originated in Germany and the key guys
they thought who they thought were
smarter than their guys were in German
they thought Heisenberg was better than
anyone on their team and actually Thomas
powers argument
book Heisenberg Schwartz controversial
argument but he basically argues that
the Germans for sure would have gone for
this if Heisenberg basically hadn't been
deliberately reticent and playing just
the opposite role of a neighbor Bush
instead of basically pushing it he
actually was pulling and being read us
and so it didn't go anywhere
interestingly the judgment that the
Germans are working on this is a
misjudgment they were actually wrong
about that unbeknownst to them the
Germans have more or less decided not to
go all out on this in the summer of
nineteen forty-two but in September in
1942 the u.s. government maybe
fortunately maybe unfortunately
according to your lights doesn't know
that and so that's a factor but my view
not still not the only factor about a
factor because I think still the key
factor is what's your theory of how
you're going to win the war this is no
longer a theory that relies on the brute
force of the US Army to carry today this
is clearly a theory that relies on naval
power as your supreme enabler everywhere
and then airpower you're still going to
bet heavily on air power there's been
some very good work that's done on where
did we get this cultural belief that air
power was a potential war winner Tammy
Biddle is written on this Michael sherry
is written on this it's very interesting
word one of the points to is that this
is very much a cultural belief that is
entire also pretty much unproven indeed
1942 is a bad year for the Air Force
advocates actually this all the
strategic bombing arguments have been
doing very badly in 1942 they've been
done they've done badly and 41 for the
British they're doing badly in 1942 and
19-43 they will do even worse
unbeknownst to them in 1943 the
strategic of embodiment offensive will
basically fail pretty spectacularly by
the end they actually even at the end of
42 they have to make a strategic call
going into the casablanca conference on
are we really going to keep relying
heavily on the air campaign and instead
of basically pulling back from it they
double the bet and then have a terrible
year in 1943 in which it doesn't work at
all until all of a sudden they figure
out how to solve the problem in early
1944 actually that's when actually that
bet begins to prove out because they
from Cleveland's they developed
long-range fighter escorts above all the
p-51 Mustang and then deployed it in and
then deployed it in numbers in early
nineteen forty four and then that
dramatically changed the whole air power
equation of Europe but that's kind of a
digression and different story the point
is is they have a theory of how to win
the war that's also substantially
conjectural and actually most of the
empirical evidence available to them
then and for some time is against it
that's embedded in that theory to is and
what's going to happen to the bear mouth
and part of that theory is the Red
Army's going to bleed the bear model and
so embedded in that is also an
assessment of how do we think the Red
Army is going to do and is Russia likely
to survive without us and they are
coming to a judgment by the fall of
nineteen forty-two that they think
Russia is not going to collapse they
don't necessarily foresee Stalingrad
coming neither did the Germans because
the Germans in us we didn't actually see
where the Russians were going to get
another group of armies from and
actually that which is another
interesting story because it's amazing
that they actually could find and scrape
another group of our meals together but
they did and that made a big difference
but it's so point is when you unpack
this judgment this is a judgment in
which you're saying instead of the whole
way we've been developing our armed
forces to win wars what Russell Wiggly
hit once called the American Way of war
which is all about brute force we're
going to rely on brute force but in a
totally different way we're going to
rely a lot on death from above we're
going to leverage our high technology
advantages you'll look back at World War
one and see hey that's America
leveraging its high technology
advantages know it was using its farm
boys and letting the British and French
supply the high technology thank you so
there this is a different concept this
will turn out to be a fateful decision
enormously fateful decision because the
design of the American armed forces that
they put in place in 42 43 will be the
design of the American armed forces for
the next
the years that fundamental condition in
which you have a relatively weak army
and you rely heavily on high technology
above all air power above all armed with
amazing weapons to win your Wars for you
is a pattern that will be grooved deeply
into the habits of thought and culture
of the American armed forces and is to
this day it will structure the entire
military balance in Europe during the
Cold War which is structurally always
want a big red army base in smaller
Allied armies offset by air power and
nuclear weapons which will be a source
of constant tension and instability and
difficulty through the Cold War as well
and a lot of that is embedded in this
story that I've just been describing and
I think that's an interesting story in
its own right so this is I think there's
an interesting story and why America
chose to make an all-out effort to build
the atomic bomb and I've tried to
suggest to you that I think that if you
had been making an intelligence
assessment about whether or not America
would do this in say spring 1942 and
certainly in 1941 you could you would
have been pretty hard pressed to make a
really good argument as to why for sure
we were going to do this ok I think
that's fair to say indeed even in
September 42 it might not have seemed
like an obvious call and it's a product
of a particular configuration of
personalities and circumstance which
I've tried to unpack a little bit i must
tell you I I can't point today to
actually a single scholarly work that to
my view adequately recounts the story
and this is the one we know best all
right so I wanted to introduce that
story for you and spend a few minutes on
it because I want to make only one other
point to you in this talk the other
point I want to make in the talk is how
do we reason from history let's mainly
the way we reason from history about a
problem like nuclear proliferation is
there to there are basically two styles
of reasoning one of them is an illogical
and the other is direct the analogical
style of reasoning would go something
like this let's take the case of Oh Iran
Iran that's a familiar case
so the analogical version would be we
can deter Iran because deterrence of
Iran is like dot dot dot fill in the
blank de turns in the Cold War the turns
of China deterrence of we have various
analogies of deterrence and we think
those analogies worked or did not work
and therefore if those analogies worked
or did not work we form a generalization
about whether deterrence works we then
apply that generalization to Iran that's
called an illogical reason and I view
this is this form of reasoning is deeply
to the efficient and highly suspect and
extremely common and terribly seductive
because it's the most common form of
reasoning in public affairs usually
unacknowledged usually implicit and
actually the versions of this often kind
of have hidden but usually not very are
all around you if you read the
literature on the Iran story it's
everyone on the Iran rd policy argument
or another version of the analogical
reasoning could be here Iran believes
such and such and such and such well the
wrong case is like or Iran's ambitions
or Iran fears about Iran are like well
let's say Iran is like Red China we were
very worried about Red China and that
seemed really wild and irrational in the
1950s or early 1960s well maybe Iran is
like that and maybe they're not even as
wildly irrational as the Chinese seemed
to us and then them in principle the
supposition is maybe we can be a little
more relaxed about Iran because we could
have been a little more relaxed about
China it turns out or you could then say
no Iran is like Hitler's Germany and you
wouldn't want to baby wouldn't have felt
very comfortable if Hitler had acquired
an atomic bomb maybe you'd be uneasy
about that and so I'll use that now
majan if Hitler had had an atomic bomb
that's like aqua d nejad then there's
another version of an analogy ok these
are all styles of analogical reason uses
of history in that way then there are
versions of direct historical reason
a direct historical reasoning is usually
found when someone has called upon a
certified Iran expert to ride on the
subject so the typical Iran expert will
then write something that says here is
Iran's history with the United States or
with the region this has been a bad
history there have been quarrels there
has been some you chua suspicion and
fear and loathing and therefore Iran and
Iran you know has a historical tradition
of believing this or that and if we kind
of tracer on Ian historical traditions
it's always kind of naturally wanted to
be this it's always kind of naturally
wanted that and we can therefore try to
project from these traditions from these
patterns from these habits of mutual
fear and suspicion that turn out to be
exaggerated on each side one or another
belief about how we would project Iran
to behave in the future based on you
know the projection and understanding of
how Iran has behaved in the past or even
on Iran's behavior with other weapons in
the past or other situations you know
that's more direct knowledge as we're
going to look at the history of the case
at hand the history of Iran and we're
going to try to project forward from
that history or develop generalizations
about what Iran wants or doesn't want
from that history now now let's suppose
we applied those same reasons that same
style of reasoning to the case i just
spent all this time introducing to you
about America and its decisions on the
atomic bomb in 1942 notice in my I think
I think I compare that notice how you
would have gotten no almost no valuable
insight whatever from any of it you
would have if you had tried analogical
reasoning in doing the case on the
United States in 1941 1942 I don't know
where you get from that I mean that you
can people could have tried to the
United States and 41 42 is like what I
mean see there weren't even actual good
analogies of the United States behaving
this way in its major war so it's hard
to say well you know I suppose cheating
superamerica the Union
develop balloons in the Civil War you
see okay suppose you had done just
direct history I've just I'll just do a
historical study of American national
security traditions and figure out the
most likely theory in which power is
America likely to try to win this war
what weapons will it likely rely on what
strategies will it likely adopt if I was
working in German military intelligence
in summer of nineteen forty-two and
trying to project the likely shape white
and direction of American military power
that would be wielded against and I
think you could get somewhere with that
I think that would be of some value but
as far as shedding a lot of light on the
particular story I just hold I think
it's very hard so let's if you were to
look at the Iran case today and someone
was asking me earlier today if you
wanted to do a study of Iran today what
would be an example of how you would
work on Iran well let's take a
historical case on a mom let's just
discard the analogical reasoning all
together and let's just say that we
wanted to do some direct historical work
on Iran we actually know of a particular
decision Iran has made about nuclear
matters that was very significant Iran
made the decision to quit the moratorium
and resume uranium enrichment it appears
to have made that decision no later than
some time in 2004 that's a decision we
know they made at the decision we know
they thought was significant so then you
would think if you will use my example
of the American case and you think about
the level of detail I needed to get into
to try to explain that case to you and
said okay then what level of detail
would I need to get into to be
comparable II have a stab at being
comparably insightful about Iran that's
like I when who why when did iran make
that decision in about resuming uranium
enrichment and then to the best of my
knowledge can I bound that time frame
you know to one degree or another who
exactly made it I mean to actually make
a list of the names
and the positions they held and the
institutional environment in which they
operate so you like Vannevar Bush as an
atomized name if they understand who is
van eager bush what are his concerns
what's his world what is the office of
scientific research and development but
part of it is the personal relationships
he has right as opposed to say a Verner
Heisenberg so you would then you want to
look at the names and then who are these
and what is the institutional
environment in which they specifically
operated at that time and what are the
different relationships and so on and
then why did they make that decision and
then of course you wouldn't want to just
look at the wise having to do with
atomic issues what were all the concerns
in those people's heads at that point in
time what were all the assessments they
would have made notice in the American
case there are a whole lot of other
issues going on there that they were
weighing and calculating most of them
not having to do with atomic matters
because the people who actually made
that decision none of them were doing
atomic research they had some
representations about the state of
atomic research being made to them by
others that they chose to believe so you
begin to think about that kind of level
of analysis that you then apply to that
case and I would think you begin to
surface then the character of the
problem in analyzing a case like say the
Iranian case I mean I've had to work on
a little bit of this problem myself in
the real world because when i was in
government that last time as counselor
of the department of state in 2005 and
2006 i was very much concerned with iraq
and i was very much concerned with why
is Iran doing so much to intervene in
the Iraqi in Iran and the Iraqi conflict
and kill American soldiers and the
Iranian Iranian were doing this in a big
way and this is a subject of some
concern because if Iran ians are
intervening in this war and Iranians are
directly responsible for killing
Americans well gee we usually do
something when people kill our soldiers
we usually do something to the people
who are doing that and I actually
visited and I saw for myself what they
were doing to our soldiers and you're
going to if you do that you're going to
want to do something about it and do
something that people
were making it happen so I spent a lot
of time trying to figure out who makes
who's making these decisions in Iran and
these decisions are significant
decisions in which substantial resources
were invested there was some flurry of
controversy about this back when it
finally surfaced publicly no no they
couldn't be doing it that controversy I
think now has subsided I mean the
evidence on this overwhelming was not
cooked up by politico's in the White
House it was very much a ground-up stuff
being done by the forensics of the
soldiers who were encountering these
weapons in the field and then working
them back and of course we now we've
actually captured Hezbollah operatives
who were imported from Lebanon or
training in Iranian camps and then
deployed from the Iranian camps for
combat inside Iraq killing Americans and
we know a little bit about Iranian
tactical management of the kill
operations and things like that so you
asked why are they doing this who's
doing this why are they doing it how can
we influence their calculations on this
point and i will tell you that from my
experience in working these issues i
found them very humbling because
actually we don't know very much about
who's making these decisions I'll tell
you what you do know and what is
humbling is boy the more you know about
this the more you know you do not
understand their world and their world
is a very distinctive world it is not
the world of quote Iran it is even in
some ways not even the world of the
Iranian Revolutionary Guards Corps which
itself is a very distinctive
institutional and organizational culture
it is even parts and subsets within that
world affections of people who've known
each other for a long time we've gone
back and have done a lot of things
together and they've been involved in a
lot of they've suffered a lot of brutal
things together and they've done a lot
of brutal things together these are
people who have themselves personally
killed other people in various
operations in different places this is a
tough group foals and they pride
themselves in their toughness it's a
badge of honor to them it says we know
how to do tough things unlike some
people unlike these these soft
foreigners we sometimes encounter we're
tough guys and they're not and they have
a very particular beauty of the world
and it varies to some extent among them
and actually they talk a lot about their
view of the world
in different ways because they have to
talk to each other and there's a
spectrum of views about that but the
more I got into that and of course these
are mostly people who aren't very
well-traveled who don't know a whole lot
about the outside world and what they do
know comes to them through very unusual
prisms refracted in very interesting
ways and so we kind of constructing what
do they believe is going on in the world
what are they what kind of action
judgments are they making I just found
this is it's just extremely hard to
understand and so I'm humbled by it and
I'm i feel very modest about it but then
that then takes me back to then how do
you deal with situations of modesty and
uncertainty and risk and that's an
important theme in all of these stories
notice even back in the American story
that I was talking about how much is
involved even in the American judgments
about conjecture about risks about what
risks they're prepared to accept you
know that hundred division gamble they
made for the army actually almost does
not pay out they actually by early
nineteen forty-five we actually ran out
of combat soldiers I'm ran out of combat
soldiers they begin scraping the rear
areas in England and even back in the
states they first of all by early 44
they already they had a program that the
college kids can get extra training
first because we want to keep all our
college kids from being killed they
scrapped that in early 44 and just
through the college kids into the line
by early 45 they are already there even
my god enlisting Negro soldiers on a
much larger scale in combat then they
have been willing to do before because
they're out of combat soldiers there
they're actually at the point where
they're beginning to have to cannibalize
their existing divisions to make it
replacements for their losses which the
British by the way had been doing for
the previous six months that's how bad
the manpower picture was by early
nineteen forty-five we were kind of out
of Schlitz all the people who could be
deployed were deployed all the people
who could be sent into combat were there
and we were fortunately the war didn't
last a whole lot longer from that
perspective so the hundred division
gamble turned out not to be an easy
gamble
we got kind of lucky on some things
including some of the ones in the way
the fighting went and some of the ways
in which we compensated for a relatively
light and lightly equipped army but
they're making a lot of conjectural
judgments some of them based on accurate
guesses some of them based on inaccurate
information like about the German
program or inaccurate guesses and that's
the compound that they're dealing with
so all I wanted to do today is due to
things is first I wanted to tell you a
historical story that I think is kind of
interesting in its own right and then
second since that's just presumably a
story that we Americans should feel like
we understand extremely well to then
relate that as how you would reason from
history about any other case study you
carried a name which we're bound to
understand less well I'll stop there
open the floor to your questions
understand but i would ask everyone
who'd like to pose a question and please
come forward to the microphone because
we are recording this so Frank I think
you may or may not make it to the front
first but ok all right Frank Kevin
Philip that was as always a tremendous
performance as always I learned a ton
from you I couldn't agree with you more
about the u.s. example and the fact that
we need to know more about it but as I
was thinking about your very powerful
argument I thought are you only
capturing half the story here what
you're trying to explain and I think
this is an important part of the debate
about proliferation is why states make
certain decisions and I think that is
you're absolutely on point to say that
if we don't really even know our own
history of how this happens how can we
possibly speculate reason from history
about others but there's another aspect
of the proliferation debate i'm
wondering about your how history should
be
used here and that is the effect these
weapons have on the international
environment and how one should react
when a state actually has them now of
course there's a feedback loop here but
while we may not want to generalize
about why Iran is making the decisions
they're making or why North Korea is
making these decisions and making it
does strike me that it still we still
would want to think about what our
reactions could do and to do that we
would want to have some understanding on
how we think about nuclear weapons shape
incentives affect whether it makes a
play for the world more dangerous or
less dangerous place and I wondered what
role would history have in trying to
answer that how would that second
question then relate to the first
because of the second question is really
the one that actually matters in policy
the first question if you're if you're
saying what about nuclear weapons you
really care about the decision season
what you really care about is how they
shape state behavior and I was wondering
what role history can play an act sure I
think there's a lot of insight to be
gained by analyzing that the the actual
history of this dynamic like the work
that some of the work you published or
mark trachtenberg ins and some others
which is interesting and revelatory what
it does not yield I think is a reliable
generalization about the likely result
in X case X plus one what it does yield
is a family of illustrations of
different kinds of reactions in behavior
what it does then do is it in rich's
your understanding of possibilities and
therefore thoughts it's an extremely
powerful source of questions and so in
general my guidance to students in in
the study of history is history is a
wonderful source of questions but it
almost never provides an answer to the
question of the case at hand in other
words suggest the questions but it does
not answer them actually the uses of
history to answer the question
out the new case the case at hand is
fraught with problems including the
reliance then exaggerating the degree to
which you may be relying on your
historical knowledge which actually as
you pointed out tends to be is most
likely axiomatic and flawed rather than
accurate historical knowledge because
and in fact one reason that your work
and Mark's work is so interesting is
because you tend to use words in it like
the myth about all these things that are
commonly and axiomatically believed
almost universally and which are wrong
so that's one another reason not to
encourage people to rely on historical
knowledge to generalize about the next
case since their historical knowledge is
likely to be potted and mistaken but is
there for another reason to encourage
though to more effective study of know
look actually it can have a lot of
possibilities for instance if you study
the Cold War you'll find examples where
I believe Newton or even the post-cold
war era where the acquisition of nuclear
weapons has increased risks I think
you'll find examples where the
acquisition of nuclear weapons may have
decreased risks which tells me is that
there is no certain answers to what it
will be in case X there are a lot of
different possibilities and then you
really just need to do the historical
work so the first point is the analogy
suggests questions but they don't
provide answers they do not produce
general they don't produce scientific
generalizations they don't even produce
very good probabilistic generalizations
even soft generalizations in my view
that's a there are actually deeper
philosophical reasons for my conclusion
there which I won't bore you with but
then i'd say another real advantage of
historical analysis actually do the
historical work on the country but do it
at a much higher level than we're
accustomed to seeing so i gave you the
Irani allah stration so i wanted to use
historical work on Iran I gave you a
concrete example of how I would use it
on a specific historical decision we
know Iran made and I think if you
actually constructed a the best
narrative you could have that with
allowance for all the uncertainties and
sang in here we don't know this we don't
know this we don't know this we know
that these concerns were in the air at
the time among
people and here's what we don't know and
then wrote a narrative that I would find
that more insightful than any
Intelligence Estimate I have ever read
on Iran much of which talks a lot about
you know Iran's historical traditions or
patterns of Iranian behavior you know in
these kinds of unit level
generalizations which I tend to distrust
as you can tell so let's if I was
looking for example at why did taiwan as
i mentioned in an earlier session why
did taiwan choose not to acquire nuclear
weapons in the late 1980s that's
extremely interesting case about which
we do not know very much we know a
little because the Americans the
American government played a fairly
active role in that manner why did South
Korea which was embarking I believe on a
nuclear weapons program decided not to
pursue that program and then discard it
also I believe in the 1980s I think
another really interesting story not
because it will tell you what will
happen in the future case but I think it
would certainly enrich a lot of your
knowledge generally but also
specifically about that country if the
more you understood about the way the
North Korean decision-making world works
the more that would simply enrich all
your analysis of the North Korean
situation partly because it would
increase your humility and respect for
well but from what i know i need to know
more about this you know because as up
because I understand that story so well
I know some I know I here's where I need
to collect more information I don't know
enough about that institution that I
know is playing an important role on
this map that tends to play an important
role in decisions of this kind and I
need to get more on what they think
about this now who's in charge of that
institution by the way and where did
they go to school and what's the
person's service record I mean those are
all actually historical questions
institutional history and personal
history as well as the history of
particular ideas are all extremely
powerful source of insight for the case
at hand when they're not bad law rised
into kind of sort of macro
generalizations about entire countries
and societies
thank you I've been working on a book on
the Armistice in 1943 of Italy so I'm
sort of saved and all the things you've
just been talking about about World War
two but to take that analogy you know if
one looks at the Iranian experience in
the 80s 8088 i covered the iran-iraq war
as a journalist they were essentially
defeated so what do we know about the
institutional memory in their national
security policy circles about how
they're viewing this defeat and how
they're taking it as a situation where
they do want to build up a nuclear
capability to deter conventional
invasion like this or what happened with
when we knocked off their enemy in 91 in
a massive conventional victory again we
don't know and you're sort of argument
about it was sort of focusing it on the
positron on the iarc and what they were
doing and again you know it's a very
interesting thing I'm not privy to
classified information I certainly have
read a lot about what they say publicly
so it raises sort of interesting
questions about how you view history
coming into these situations and so I
just was curious about your response to
that and then you as someone who
directed the research on the 911
Commission how does that play into our
mental thinking in your mind these days
when we're viewing these issues oh
that's a terrific question and because
it's actually a source of a real insight
that's usable inside you see mainly
since I argue that we reason from
history is reasoning from history is the
most common form of reasoning and public
affairs often unacknowledged a lot of
what that consists of are we have net we
have narratives in our head about the
past that then generate axioms of
behavior and in narratives about how the
world works how things happen what has
happened to us what people perceive what
a strength what is weakness what are I a
lot of actually that is not classified
secret what you basically see for
instance you gave the excellent example
of what do the Iranians of this
particular cadre this particular group
of people or the sort of the circle
surrounding what do they think happened
in the
on a rock what is their reading event
forget what we think happened in that
war what do they think happened in that
world what was their take away from it a
lot of that is knowable because they
talk and write about this all the time
and you can get a feel for their
discourse about this it's like here's
what their takeaway has been about that
or another example could be why do they
think about what what do they think
about American performance in Iraq what
do they think actually about America
more generally in about the way America
behave what kind of history what
historical episodes or analogies or
axioms are most prominent in their head
which by the way maybe may seem to us to
be screwing or they may focus on things
that seem unimportant to us but seem
like incredibly revealing to them I
don't know but I will see us actually a
lot of that is knowable without having
to break into the most classified
information because see that's kind of
the cultural world of a group people
this is one of the reasons why I find
the dichotomies that people sometimes
draw between political history social
history and cultural history to be so
artificial because actually if you do
political history correctly you actually
have to unpack a cultural world that is
full of all kinds of idiosyncratic
beliefs about the world and about facts
and about what has happened to them
about what their history has been that
is the only way to really make sense
actually have a lot of their politics
including by the way ours what words
like Republic have meant at different
times even in our history so that's
actually a suggestion of really
insightful tools to get into their world
and unpack their world a lot of people
who have been in that world can just
they actually know a ton of stuff about
this that people actually rarely ask
them to talk about because it it doesn't
seem to form actual hard intelligence
evidence about what tubes you've
installed in a particular warehouse
which is you know we tend to really like
to collect on things and stuff but it's
actually you can actually read for
yourself characteristic ways in which
the intelligence community writes about
Iran because portions of this material
over the years has been Declassified and
the stuff that's classified believe me
is not the narrative about their culture
so you can actually read and you can get
a sense for the style and you read that
and you kind of it how much do I feel
after reading this I really understand
the world of the leadership in Iran kind
of what they their world view and I was
very frustrated with this when I was in
government and the one of the
frustrations is a lot of the people who
are working on Iran are actually very
smart about it while they actually know
a ton of stuff we have people in our
government I believe who probably listen
to Iranian telephone conversations all
day every day actually you listen to
people's telephone conversations for a
while you kind of learn a little bit
about their society just a lot of
commonplace stuff but actually you could
do it when you talk to people you can do
a lot to recreate their world when you
talk to I thought I would go out of my
way to talk to foreign diplomats who'd
served in Tehran we would be coming
through Washington for some reasons just
kind of tell me about you know tell me
about political life in Tarot just like
and you did amazing stuff that they will
just unpack to you because they're
trying really hard to get you to feel it
and it just turns out that the products
that we produce out of such processes
and actually even sometimes an academic
writing I'm afraid there's a sense that
the thermal efficiency of how knowledge
is converted into usable product is like
eight percent because it turns out that
when you actually talked to the people
they seem so knowledgeable and smart yet
somehow bureaucratically it just doesn't
seem to come out and so the kind of
question you were asking is just the
kind of question that I also sometimes
struggled with well women
well a little bit just in the sense that
again it's the way the questions that
suggests to me I mean I one of the
decisions we made in structuring the 911
report which actually at the time struck
people is unusual is it very early on
actually the very beginning I said and
of course a large part of the report
will be about al-qaeda their head at
that point already been a report done on
the intelligence community 911 done by
the house and senate joint inquiry that
didn't have a page about al-qaeda how's
school we were just investigating the
performance of the US government we
didn't have a rip investigate al-qaeda
and though it's written the way IG
reports are written which you know like
here's what you should have done and
didn't do but it's like writing a report
if you read the Pearl Harbor reports
they the US government's Pearl Harbor
reports they actually don't spend a
whole lot of time on the world of the
Japanese but actually if you spend time
on the world of al-qaeda and how they
saw the world and how this plan was
hatched and when it was hatched that
actually turns out to be really
interesting because partly they had this
very unusual worldview just able to say
the least and you know what they think
about America and what they think it
about you know what's vulnerable and
what's not vulnerable and what they want
to do you get a sense for their
operational patterns you know you know
how do people relate to bin Laden how do
their institutions work how do they
recruit operatives how do they trained
operatives how do they vet them and make
sure that they're reliable you know when
these guys show up who are expats living
in Germany volunteering how did they vet
them and kind of decide yeah we'll trust
these guys with our biggest and most
high-risk operation today and then when
you see there how the plot developed on
their side you also see oh well actually
if we had done x and y that would have
disrupted the plot because that would
like for example if we had bullet
blaring lee publicized the arrest of
Zacarias Moussaoui in august two
thousand one instead of keeping it
secret the way we blaring lee publicized
quite inadvertently by the way not as a
deliberate government choice the arrest
of achmed of assam in december 1999 when
he was caught trying to enter the United
States to
blow up part of Los Angeles Airport the
and that was a huge publicity wave about
that if there's some pretty good
evidence that if we had publicized the
rest of New sowee they would have
cancelled the operation you see they
knew what Mousawi knew that we didn't
know yet they knew if we tracked Mousawi
it would link to them because masami's
money trail turned out to be their money
trail they knew that we didn't know that
and so but they would have college
signal helmet actually told us if I'd
known captured Mousawi we live we would
have postponed the operation as we would
have thought that our security been
breached they didn't know we'd arrested
myself who they thought was kind of a
flake anyway and they just hadn't heard
from him for a little while netra did
oh alright okay sorry I thank you very
much for the talk I'm a student across
the park at a hundred college in
political science you talked about u.s.
foreign policy before World War two how
it's was a went towards attrition
bludgeoning the the enemy and then it
decided that it should go towards more
leveraging as its technology and you
know airpower things like that in your
view do you think that the in your
experience in government this whole this
new like holistic approach in like
trying to understand their world to open
up the world do you think that's a shift
and also Shipton foreign policy and when
dat that at what point maybe what when
did that happen I don't think our
government does what I was talking about
I I didn't think so and I know that I
got the sense that that's your approach
and from reading the 911 Commission
report it's like I tried to give this
little anecdote about how I was puzzling
over this particular Iran problem that I
hadn't had to encounter in my service
and which had to do with the Iranian
orchestration and provision of the
supplies and training of the people to
use some particular kinds of explosive
devices that were astonishingly lethal
and we're killing a lot of our people
and we're very much doing this with
malice aforethought and and how I tried
to puzzle over that and kind of in this
way and how hard that and that and how
hard that was I feel like I got some a
little bit of insight to that by asking
those questions and using those methods
but but mainly the you know the
institutions aren't trained to develop
information in this way would you lay
don't see that happen or do you see that
happening at all no I'm sorry you know I
don't I'm trying to let me we paused for
a moment be fair and try to think if I
can think of
an example where I'm being unfair I've
been out of government now though for
two and a half years so I'm dated
no I can't let me give you another
illustration of how interesting these
methods are if you do another early
interesting historical case actually is
Iraq we now actually know a lot about
Iraqi decisions about weapons of mass
destruction programs from 1990 to say
2003 we've you know interrogated a lot
of captives we've captured a number of
documents and there have been some
interesting reports that have been
written I haven't done the primary
sources myself so I can't vouch for the
quality the rewards they seem good to me
in the Iraqi perspectives project and
other things one of them that i thought
was exceptionally good done by a very
high quality retired intelligence
officer he actually asked exactly the
right questions and he basically said
I'm just going to sit down and it's now
after the fact and write a narrative
about Saddam Hussein's world and what
people understood in that world and what
he understood about WMD as best we can
reconstruct it from the available
evidence and that's a terrific paper and
it's not published in a book but you can
find it that I think this is part of the
dulfer report and I that I mean so there
it's another there are people who have
the talent to do this sort of work there
are plenty of them they're just not
trained and configured to to operate in
this way similar to what you mentioned
about the ship from focusing on the army
to the technical side how much do you
think that sort of mentality still
drives the current military operation in
particular with the drone bombing in
Pakistan because we always hear about
the collateral damage and how much that
sort of makes more enemies but it's
still happening and I don't I mean it
seems like it's a self-defeating
operation so why is that still going on
in your mind well actually at the micro
level and one of the things that I've
encountered in my experience is that
this is the problem that we've just been
talking about about the reconstruction
of other people's world gets much better
the closer you get to the field and the
more you get to people who are working
on particular individuals so for
instance if you were to go to an embassy
and then you're go to the people in the
embassy who you know interact every day
with a particular office or minister and
you just like tell me about this guy
tell me about this office they know a
lot and they r it and they get a lot now
let's take the illustration that you
just offer people who are working on and
at particular al-qaeda problems let's
say al qaeda in iraq or al-qaeda bases
in pakistan they have now zeroed in on a
number of individuals and interactions
between individuals for a long time with
every asset of the US government that
they can muster and they actually have
they have tried to do a lot to
reconstruct their the world of a handful
of people so they may have drones for
instance surveillance drones that just
kind of hover over places for a long
time and try to just get a sense of who
travels with whom where do people go
what are the ways in which they move
what are the ways in which they meet
when they meet what do they do how our
operations planned you get a lot of
information after an operation sometimes
and you can reconstruct okay that's how
this worked and so when you what you'll
find is close to the field are people
who have really quite masterful detailed
knowledge about petit these particular
groups that they have been focused on
very hard not always the case but it is
sometimes the case and therefore when
they decide to shoot sometimes they
shoot very accurately because they
probably they may have had four other
occasions where they could have taken a
shot and decided not to and that one
they did and that's one reason why
frankly we broke and rolled up most of
al Qaeda in Iraq as we gain that kind of
mastery of knowledge about the way al
Qaeda in Iraq worked to the point and
actually interestingly a lot of the
breakthroughs in the interrogations
process came after we quit using the
bully-boy tactics and just began
interrogating under field man
rules beginning in 04 05 and
incidentally we found that we did it we
conducted a natural experiment on
methods of interrogation incidents as a
footnote or we've tried different
methods of interrogation against
al-qaeda simultaneously in a
double-blind experiment without meaning
to do it is what scientists call a
natural experiment and actually the we
did very well against al-qaeda in Iraq
and we would in real time could get
people could okay they could tell us
some stuff that fit three pieces into
the mosaic completed the mosaic and an
hour half later you rolled out another
raid in the same night and then rolled
out the next node in the network and
even maybe the next note after that and
really broke that organization it's
beginning to reconstitute some now as
our presence draws down and so on but
the point is that we have there are
people out there who intuitively get
these skills and apply these skills in
working micro problems and and and the
way these are very valuable skills if
you talk to them they understand they're
very interested in people's histories
its historical knowledge on the micro
scale who is this guy who d know who's
his family where do you know where do
you go to school where is he trained
they would they want to know all that
stuff about them they want to know the
personal history they want to know the
institutional history this like they
want to know the forensic history of the
objects I capture I wanted to ask you
about historical narrative about the
german reunification from your book and
one thing i noticed reading your book
but also reading some of the other
memoirs from this time is that for
example there was a very important
meeting when president bush was in
poland in july of 1989 and he actually
signed a military agreement with general
aerosol scheme and as a result of it she
invited to the polished journals to come
to a NATO meeting in canada at the
beginning of august of 1918
and then they came to Washington and
that was sort of the first breakthrough
in the Cold War that this was actually
the first time since before World War
two where they invited these people here
and it was you know followed by some of
the more conventional arms control
understandings that later developed into
something else but I didn't see that in
your book and I didn't see it in print
scroll crop spoke and I think that maybe
it affects the historical narrative out
than the german reunification because it
was sort of the first breakthrough and i
wonder if you could tell me you know was
that a sort of a conscious decision not
to include dead or it was secret I don't
know I mean I I know it was there and I
was there by the way but you know I just
wondered I think it would affect this
historical narrative of the end of the
Cold War but for some reason it was not
included and I wanted to ask you why
well of course the first explanation is
the in competence of the author and
that's that's the default text that's
the default explanation is just
negligence the second possibility is
you're right i was there and i did have
some responsibility for these issues
back then back then and if i didn't
include it because i didn't think it was
important I didn't I barely to DC I
don't even remember knowing about it so
it made it registered no impression on
me whatever if I knew about it at all
and since at the time it didn't seem
important to me or to anyone in my
office at the white house and I saw no
sign that it seemed important to any of
the Germans we were dealing with or any
other European government we were
dealing with on this on the German
issues I didn't mention it now it could
be that there is a whole story there and
if you dig into the story you'll find
evidence that this turns out to really
be important and the Americans just
missed it Americans didn't know about it
and missed it quite possible
I'm but it mean we were we were
following a course and Bob Hutchings who
is sitting next door to me in the NSC
staff was on the trip with President
Bush to Poland and followed polish
issues even more closely than I did and
he taught it he didn't wave his hand
about it much either we were very
interested in a lot of other things
having to do Poland which was enormously
important though I did not think Pola I
think Poland is was an absolutely
pivotal link in the chain to the erosion
of Soviet power in the process that we
associate with the end of the Cold War I
did not think Poland actually was a very
important link in the chain to the
unification of Germany which is
something that poles did were not
anxious to see in that respect the
developments in Hungary were actually
much more important that in August of
1989 and that was actually mostly a
stuff that happened between Hungarians
and the Germans not with on earrings and
us though we were more aware of it and
we're playing a benevolent role but in
general the the poles who played once
again a pivotal historical role were I
think it's fair to say at ambivalent at
best about anything that would make the
Germans stronger or bring the bring the
Germany's back together again and though
I did end up spending quite a lot of
time on polish issues in early nineteen
ninety when their fears became acute I
had to chuckle a little bit when you
made your comment about how one can
learn a lot from a country by listening
to telephone conversations the film the
lives of others came to mind and I have
a question for though about your how do
you maintain balance between these two
different worlds of history and
policymaking seem to do a very admirable
job at that and many of my classmates
and colleagues would like to do similar
things with balancing these two
different worlds so do you have any
advice for us well it wasn't planned
I saw the product of serendipity I
really was i I get asked by students a
lot kind of you seem to have had some
interesting jobs can you please now
divulge the secret master plan because
I've been following a master plan for
the last 20 years I've been pretty good
at it so far I just need to know what
the next chapter is pleased and I'm a
very poor guy I mean on every point I I
was a trial and appellate lawyer before
I went back to graduate school and then
after leaving after going back to
graduate school again by the way because
I wanted to do something I wanted to try
doing something in foreign affairs
before I gave up on it and went back to
my law practice which I love by the way
but I had no idea how to have a career
in foreign affairs I'd never met anyone
who had ever had such a career all of
you know much more about this sort of
thing than I did I'd never met such
person I knew they existed because I saw
them on TV and in magazines and there
was a school i found that claim to teach
people in this field from its catalog so
i applied to it and they let me in and
then I did okay there and and then when
I want I decided well if I really want
to do foreign policy I guess I best way
to do foreign policy is to do foreign
policy so I joined the Foreign Service
and how do i did i just took the exam so
it's and then I was always very
interested in history and then I had a
chance sexually to go into academia and
of course instantly began doing history
work because that was the work I really
wanted to do and but interest the German
ebook overlapped a lot with my
government work but after the Germany
book I've tried with some effect not a
in general to keep my scholarship
actually a little bit distant from the
work i do on current events i find that
that's important and helpful I mean
occasionally then if you know in the 911
Commission I had an opportunity to kind
of if you were approaching this as a
scholar and this had happened a hundred
years ago how would you work on this and
write about it
and you know that's a useful mental
exercise even though I mean I knew lots
of people involved in both the Clinton
and the Bush administration's is very
important to just kind of try to think
about them as if they were historical
figures in the distant past oddly enough
you know historians tend to actually
develop by it's very strong vicarious
relationships with dead people so it's
not that being distant from these people
means that you no longer care about them
and you're not their friends you
actually develop very strong and
passionate sometimes passionate
attachments even where you really you
take sides in their world that distant
dead world because you actually mostly
live in that distant dead world because
you that's you travel to that world
that's the world you actually struggle
to live in enough that you can interpret
it to the people of the present and so
since you spend yogurt I'm living in
that world you form attachments in it
and so in a Wyatt distance from events
is also no sure guide to objectivity
about them you have a couple of
questions from our online audience that
I'm sorry and that you will have the
last question sir let go Hannah yeah why
don't you do both of them at the same
thing sure thank you very much for your
interesting lecture it has definitely
sparked some interesting questions in
our online discussion which I was
moderating at the back there while we
streamed your lecture live the first
question comes from one of the students
in our program her name is margarita the
question reads as follows you mentioned
the leveraging of high technology in the
perception of strength / advantage of
air power there has been recent
discussion of possible air strikes on
Iran's nuclear facilities in looking at
Israel's historical use of air power to
strike Iraq and Syria's nuclear
facilities do you think that the
international community might be open to
using air power to disrupt the Iranian
nuclear program so that is our first
question and then the second question
comes from another member of our program
who's off doing research as well his
name is Taunton thank you for your
excellent lecture he says your argument
about the role of contingency in the
atomic decision in 1942 shows a
difficulty of analogical historical
for understanding contemporary events
however you also noted that a closer of
for instance Iranian cultural history
sorry a closer look I believe could lead
to a better understanding of Iranian
decisions do you believe that historical
analysis beyond the scale of
contemporary history could assist in
better foreign policy decision-making
Thanks yes let me start the second
question first yes I do believe
historical analysis beyond contemporary
history can be enormously helpful I'll
give you an illustration of this it's
not and it's not my illustration there
is a wonderful book that was written by
a woman named English Inga Clendenin I
know that I've got the last name right
called reading the Holocaust and it's
basically working in which she attempts
to really analyze the Holocaust and
trying to unpack the cultural world of
the people who are doing this and how
they made all this make sense to them in
critically evaluating a variety of
source material about the Holocaust it's
a terrific book and was very widely
praised at the time even by people in
the Holocaust fuel but interestingly how
to clendenon get the expertise to come
by this clendenon last major work before
she did this work was on the aztec
priesthood basically a dead nation of
five hundred years ago but of course
this is a bloodthirsty priesthood with a
bloody cold and she approached it kind
of almost as a slat historian /
anthropologist learning how to
interrogate sources to unpack seemingly
exotic and bizarre cultural rituals
sanguinary rituals and in effect the
tools and techniques that she developed
the sense of empathy she could develop
across time to strange subjects was the
enabler for her to be able to write a
really important and influential book to
understand the holocaust thing
I think there are a lot of the other
illustrations one can draw on again it
didn't of course apply any of the
answers she didn't at no point in the
book that she say this guy reminds me
this guy's like an Aztec no but it gave
her it enabled her enriched her ability
to ask questions and work with her
sources in intriguing ones in May Day
for a richer account it improved the
quality of thought at the margin and
actually that's a lot of what you can do
and I mean when I retrans national
historical accounts or other things it's
me you know it's a lot of what I'm just
trying to do is open my mind enrich my
understanding tune me in two frequencies
that I ordinarily don't hear that are
beyond the range of my hearing so then
maybe I'll here just a little bit better
tomorrow if you do something that
improved the quality of your thought at
the margin by one percent that's a lot
so and there and boy is history am a
tremendous well from which you can draw
your whole life in this way just
constantly enriching the quality of your
thought to the first question that you
asked was much more current events
question it was the is the past Israeli
experience with striking Iran in 1981
excuse me in Iraq in 1981 and Syria in
2007 presaged something on Iran I
wouldn't I mean of course in 1981 the
world disapproved of what they did at
the time and approved greatly of it much
later in 2007 the reaction of the world
to it was actually very interesting the
reaction of the world was basically
silence eloquent silence so but what the
Israelis would take with me I wouldn't
think of that as that's not an
analogical point it's huh how do the
Israeli leadership which will make
decisions about it Ron read those
reactions they may not read them the way
I've read them but
may you know in other words what is the
narrative in their heads now in the way
they have now interpreted that recent
history my guest by the way is they
interpret Israeli leadership today
interprets both of these episodes as
successes and regards the leadership
that approved those strikes as wise as
having been wise you or I might or might
not disagree with that appraisal but if
I've just stated a correct judgment that
is now a useful insight for analysis of
the next problem now the next problem
has many complications and trade-offs of
its own as the Israelis understand very
well but in that sense you can see that
historical knowledge is useful but the
fact that you think you have a
historical understanding of what
happened doesn't necessarily mean that
the people you're examining have the
same knowledge and interpret it in the
same way let me just give you a another
quick and illustration of this since
it's so vivid and powerful is there's
been a lot written for instance about
predicting the fall of the Soviet Union
the breakup of the Soviet Union CIA's
analysis of the Soviet economy and so on
one of the fascinating works on that
literature is conclusions that I draw
from it is that the CIA got to the point
where they understood the condition of
the Soviet economy better than Mikhail
Gorbachev did in retrospect I think view
dispassionately I think that that is a
correct statement in a way they were
smarter than Gorbachev was about his own
country does that help you interpret and
assess Gorbachev no in fact it screws up
your assessment of Gorbachev because
it's the from policymakers point of view
it's what Gorbachev thinks about his own
economy that's going to determine now
then you can say well he doesn't
understand this we can influence him to
do something we would like if we may be
helped him understand something else may
gave him some information or presented
him with a briefing or some you know
then you can make arguments like that
but it's a really powerful illustration
of
in a way one reason that we are we were
having trouble assessing the Soviet
government is because our analysis of
their situation was different and
superior to their own analysis of the
situation to this question about how you
respond to proliferate errs if we're in
a mode of sanctions diplomacy with
respect to Iran and Iraq what does
history tell us about moving up to
redline diplomacy I'm thinking of
conceivably ultimatums and also could
you just briefly the numbers don't add
up on your hundred division army I was
under the impression that there were 12
million Americans under arms World War 2
100 division armies only a million so
maybe I'm losing I missed something in
the calculus yeah in the first part that
I'm just going to ask you to trust me on
this and the number the number people
have worked these numbers and it just
turns out that to feel the combat
division that may have a TOA of 14,000
there you know there are a hundred
thirty thousand people behind that
division along the chain going back to
the training camps and so on then you if
you kind of do the work on them how many
people you have to field then how many
I'm yeah these are these are combat
units these are not support units and so
what's happening actually an early 45 is
there repeatedly coming through the
support units in England even back in
the United States to basically fill out
the replacement depots in Paris and find
more people to throw into the line
because they basically run out of combat
infantryman because they we were losing
them about we were losing them weight
faster than we had thought we would and
but it is remarkable that you get that
the tip of the spear seem so small in
relation to the whole size of the spear
but it is a fact and actually we ended
up only being able week we quit creating
new divisions in 1944 we simply just
that's it for done
no more no more new numbers coming out
last divisions last number divisions hit
Europe in the fall of 44 one of them was
actually rounded up by the Germans in
December and that was it and then from
then on in the war it was find
replacements and make it up and then if
we that's why when if we were going to
do Japan we were going to do Japan with
combat units in Europe because there
wasn't any other place to find them and
literally the guys who'd actually
already been fighting for all this time
I mean we basically fought our soldiers
till they frankly till they drew till
they were killed or wounded or suffered
from incurable stress the first question
you had about how to what do you learn
about how to draw red lines and deliver
all tomato as you can tell from my talk
I'm very suspicious of a generalization
about this but I the cut the
generalization I can confidently offer
is that bread lines and ultimate often
don't work so and I cannot specify the
pre-existing conditions if you do the
ultimate in this particular way you
there is a eighty percent chance that it
will work the next time based on my
study of if you get if you kind of just
do the philosophy of science problem
here in developing a probabilistic
generalization of this kind so all you
can do is you can say well sometimes
they work and sometimes they done Israel
has drawn certain red lines that for
reasons that we may not fully understand
have been respected in some cases but
for instance right now with a lot of
Iranian support very large numbers of
ballistic missiles are being
concentrated to rain down in Israeli
cities based in the state of 11 so if
that happens what will Israel do about
that is that cross some kind of Israeli
red line I don't know so but the main
answer to your question is red lines
often don't work and you then really
just have to do if I do a red line on
this particular place in this particular
time period on this particular country
do I think I will reduce
the risk that the red line will be
crossed because see mostly what you're
doing is you're nobody's offering you a
guarantee you're mostly just in the
world of IP need to raise risks so I can
even lower risks and oftentimes what I
do to lower risks creates other kinds of
risks and so usually the art of judgment
and public affairs is how i balance the
trade-offs among my wrists and my
management of risk alright well thank
you again those